NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF
A QUORUM THE SERGEANT AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER
CHAMBERS AND BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER CLERK PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ACOSTA.
BAG WE ARE CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRUNO.
BURKE.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
SO BONTA.
CHAO.
CHAVEZ.
GEN DAVID CHIU.
CHAUDHRY.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALLEY.
DALY.
EGGMAN.
FLORA.
FONG.
FRASER.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER IN A GARCIA.
AND WATER GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON.
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI.
MS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
REYES.
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SOLACE
SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND.
T..
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR TODAY'S
INVOCATION.
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB
OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THE HONOR OF RECEIVING A
POSITION OF RESPONSIBILITY. IS A
PRIVILEGE WE MUST EARN EVERY
DAY.
AFTER OVER FIVE YEARS OF
GRADUATE STUDIES HALF OF WHICH
WERE SPENT IN KYOTO. I RETURNED
FULLY ORDAINED AT THE AGE OF
ALMOST TWENTY SEVEN.
WITHIN WEEKS OF RETURNING I WAS
REUNITED WITH MY PRIMARY
MENTORING DEAR FRIEND. DOCTOR
MAKSIM YUKI.
AS WE WERE BEING DRIVEN TO A
DINNER AT THE BISHOPS RESIDENTS
IN BELMONT.
DOCTOR MIUKI ASKED ME.
BOB.
DO YOU TRUST ME.
I QUICKLY RESPONDED OF COURSE.
THEN HE SAID IF I WERE TO ASK
YOU TO DO SOMETHING FOR ME WOULD
YOU.
WITHOUT HESITATION ANSWERED.
WHATEVER YOU ASKED OF ME I WOULD
TRY TO DO.
HE SAID REALLY.
I ASSURED HIM THAT I TRUSTED HIM
COMPLETELY.
THEN VERY SERIOUSLY HE SAID.
WE'RE GOING TO THE BISHOPS HOME
FOR DINNER TONIGHT.
WHEN WE SEE HIM.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO TELL HIM
THAT YOU WERE QUITTING THE
MINISTRY.
WHEN HE ASSURED ME THAT HIS
REQUEST WAS GENUINE. WITH MUCH
RELIEF I TOLD THEM OF COURSE I
WOULD DO IT.
SMILING HE ASKED REALLY.
I TOLD THEM THAT I TOO WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT MY ABILITY TO
FULFILL THIS NEW ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY.
AS MY MOST TRUSTED MENTOR. I
FELT HE TO SENSE THAT I WAS NOT
READY.
WHEN EXPRESS MY SENSE OF RELIEF
ARE LAUGHTER WAS A SHARED JOY.
WE TALKED HAPPILY THE REST OF
THE DRIVE.
AS WE APPROACH THE BISHOPS HOME.
HE SAID AGAIN SO BOB. YOU REALLY
TRUST. AND YOU WOULD DO IF I
ASKED.
SMILING AND NODDING I SAID OF
COURSE.
THEN HE LOOKED AT ME WARMLY AND
SAID.
THEN I WANT YOU TO STAY.
WE MAY HAVE LAUGHED AGAIN BUT.
IT WAS MORE SUBDUED KNOWING
SMILE.
MY MENTOR AND DEAR FRIEND WAS
TESTING ME.
HE WANTED TO SEE IF I WAS
ATTACHED
TO THE ROLE IN TITLE I HAD
RECEIVED.
I ALSO SENSED THAT HE WAS HAPPY
AND RELIEVED TO SEE THAT. I
REMAIN THE SEEKER I WAS WHEN HE
EMBRACED ME SIX YEARS BEFORE.
ALTHOUGH NIKE SENSEI HAS PASSED.
HE IS WITH ME EVERYDAY.
I HEAR HIM ALWAYS IN MY HEART
ASKING ME.
ARE YOU WORTHY OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES YOU HAVE BEEN
ENTRUSTED TO BEAR.
AND MY HEART ICY TO HIM SENSEI
I'M TRYING.
IN LIFE IF WE ARE FORTUNATE WE
WILL BE GIVEN GREAT ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES.
BUT THE GREATEST OF ALL IS TO BE
TRUE TO OURSELVES AND THE PEOPLE
WHO LOVE AND RELY ON US.
THE GREATER THE RESPONSIBILITIES
WE ARE ENTRUSTED WITH.
THE MORE WE STE YOU MUST AVOID
ANY SENSE OF ENTITLEMENT.
INSTEAD WE MUST TRY TO FULFILL
OUR RULES WITH HONESTY HUMILITY.
AND GRATITUDE.
NUMBER ONE. WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND.
I INVITED TO REMAIN STANDING FOR
TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE WILL TO
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA.
MEMBERS AND GUESTS PLEASE JOIN
IN THE SLEEP I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF. THE UNITED
STATES.
WHICH IS.
NATION. OUR
INDIVISIBLE.
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY MARCH WE
WANT TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
CEMENT AT SEVEN AM THE ARTICLE
CALDERON MOVES TO MISTER DALLI
SECONDS AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
RESOLUTIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
RECORDED IN TODAY'S JOURNAL.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW SOMEONE
MAYES.
AS WELL AS FRAZIER TO SPEAK ON.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS COMMITTEE.
S. B. SEVENTY ONE WINNER FROM
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY EIGHT ALLEN
FROM EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY
SIX TO ALLOW THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO
SET AB. THIRTY TEN FOR HEARING
ON APRIL SEVENTEENTH PENDING RE
REFER A FROM THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
TODAY IN THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE
GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BIGELOW PRISCUS
INTRODUCTION MISTER BIGELOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
IF YOU'LL PLEASE LOOK UP IN THE
GALLERY TODAY WE HAVE
AUDIBLE GROUP WITH US TODAY I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MISTER DOUG
DEAL CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
AIRCRAFT ASSOCIATION AND ITS
ENTIRE SUPPORTED DIRECTORS IS
WITH THEM PLEASE GIVE THEM A
WARM. RECEPTION.
LAKE
THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SO WE WILL TWENTY TEAM WITH A
MEMBERS TWENTY THREE SIXTEEN
WITH THE MALES TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY NINE OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY FORTY SIX OF
THE MEMBERS SEVENTY FORTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY NINE
NINETY WITH A MINUTES.
TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE OF THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO
THE MINUTES EIGHTEEN A FIVE THE
MINUTES NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE THE
MEMBERS TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
THE MINUTES TWENTY TWO SEVEN
FOUR THE MEMBERS TWENTY HUNDRED.
TWENTY SIX SIXTY NINE TWENTY
FOUR NINETY FIVE NINETEEN OH
THREE NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TWENTY. TWO
THOUSAND ONE TWO TWENTY ONE OF
THREE TWENTY FIVE FIFTY SEVENTY
SIXTY SIX EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
NINETEEN OH NINE NINETEEN
TWENTY.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR TWENTY FIFTY TWO
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN TWENTY ONE SIXTY NINE
TWENTY ONCE EVERY SIX.
TWENTY ONE NINETY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO ONE TWENTY TOOL FOR TWENTY
THREE OH NINE TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE NINETEEN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY TWO. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY THREE
FORTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE OH TWO.
THREE THOUSAND TO THE MINUTES
TWO THOUSAND I'M OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE WITH A
BEVERAGE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
WITH A BEVERAGE TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX OF THE MINUTES.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT WITH
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE SIXTY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS FIFTY
ONE THROUGH SIXTY OUR CONTINUED.
MOVING BACK TO GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR CURRY.
FOR A GUEST INTERRUPTION FOR
MISTER CALDERON STUFF.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
SICILIAN WHILE.
I REPRESENT ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FOR AND TODAY I AM DELIGHTED. TO
INTRODUCE THE LADY WOLVES OF
WOODLAND HIGH SCHOOL AND
CONGRATULATE THEM ON THE WINNER
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
DIVISION TO NOR CAL. REGIONAL
CHAMPIONSHIP. THEY DEFEATED
BRANSON SCHOOL IN A VICTORY OF
TWO TO ONE ON MARCH TENTH.
ITSELF EVERYBODY WELCOME MY
FRIENDS FROM WHAT.
AND.
THANK YOU MOVING NOW TO ITEM
SIXTY ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME OF BILL SEVENTY FORTY SIX A
BY SOME MEMBERS OF OUR TEST
ANOTHER TONIGHT LEAD TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO PROTECT SURVIVORS BY
EXPEDITING THE PROCESS OF
PROSECUTING SERIAL OFFENSES. OF
SEXUAL BATTERY AND UNLAWFUL
SEXUAL INTERCOURSE WHICH IS
COMMONLY KNOWN AS STATUTORY RAPE
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
PROSECUTION A CERTAIN CRIMES CAN
BE CONSOLIDATED INTO A SINGLE
TRIAL. IF THE PERPETRATOR
COMMITTED THEM ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS THE LIST OF
ELIGIBLE CRIMES CURRENTLY
INCLUDE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND CHILD
ABUSE.
HOWEVER THIS LIST IS NOT INCLUDE
SEXUAL BATTERY OR STATUTORY
RAPE.
THIS MEANS THAT A SURVIVOR WHO
IN DURING ONE OF THESE OFFENSES
MUST BE FORCED TO TESTIFY OUT
MULTIPLE TRIALS IN FORCED TO
RELIVE THIS ORDEAL HERE SHE
INJURED. THIS COULD BE VERY
TRAUMATIC FOR VULNERABLE
SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY CHILDREN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX WILL SOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
ADDING THESE OFFENSES TO THE
LIST OF ELIGIBLE CRIMES FOR
CONSOLIDATION INTO A SINGLE
TRIAL.
THIS WILL PROTECT SURVIVORS FROM
HAVING TO TESTIFY ABOUT THE
TRAUMA THE INJURED I MULTIPLE
TRIALS REDUCE COURT COSTS IN
ALLOW FIRST READ THE RENDERING
OF SWIFT JUSTICE TO THE
PERPETRATORS OF THESE HEINOUS
CRIMES.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SUMMER STUFF IN THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND THE
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
LIKE MY MOM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISING THAT PROUD COAUTHOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX.
CRIME SURVIVOR SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO RELY.
RELIVE THE TRAUMA MORE THAN ONCE
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT RAPE AND
SEXUAL BATTERY SURVIVORS.
ONLY HAVE TO TESTIFY ONCE IN
COURT EVEN IF THE CRIME HAPPENED
IN MORE THAN ONE TOWNIE.
THIS IS THE COMMONSENSE MEASURE
THAT SUPPORT RECOVERY FOR THOSE
AFFECTED BY THESE CRIMES ARE
STRONGER DRIVE VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR FOR THE
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION MISTER
CLICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE I
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO.
THE MOTION PASSED THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY TWO. ACR
ONE SEVENTY TWO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I'M SORRY MR CLERK PLEASE READ
ASSUMING CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
AND TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS.
THANK YOU S. M. EVER LOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER ACR
ONE SEVENTY TWO FORMALLY
APOLOGIZES FOR THE PAST LAWS.
AND BE CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISIONS
THAT DISCRIMINATED AGAINST LGBT
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF ENACTING LEGISLATION
THAT IS DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
LGBT PEOPLE.
FOR EXAMPLE PUBLIC THE INDECENCY
CODES WERE USED TO HARASS AND
ARREST PEOPLE. WHO WERE THAT
DEFINED AS LGBT AND WHO DEFIED A
GENDER NORMS?
AS WRITTEN.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW DEFINES
MARRIAGE BETWEEN A MAN AND A
WOMAN AND TWO THOUSAND VOTERS
PASSED PROPOSITION TWENTY TWO
WHICH BANNED. SAME SEX MARRIAGE
WASN'T UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN THAT THE NIGHT STATE
SUPREME COURT RULED THAT
PROPOSITION EIGHT WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND THAT
MARRIAGE EQUALITY BECAME LEGAL
IN CALIFORNIA.
ALLOWS IT IN IMPORTANT THAT'S AN
APOLOGY CANNOT UNDO THAT DECADES
OF.
PERSECUTION AND OPPRESSION IT
ISN'T AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
RECOGNIZE THE PAST MISTAKES MADE
BY PREVIOUS GOVERNING BODIES.
WITH RESPECT I ASK FOR THE
FIRST ROLE TO BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE SEVENTY TWO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY. HAS SUFFERED AND
CONTINUES TO ENTER UNIMAGINABLE
OBSTACLES
NO INDIVIDUAL SHOULD FACE
INJUSTICE OF ANY KIND FOR BEING
TRUE TO ONESELF.
THE JEWISH CAUCUS WILL ALWAYS
WELCOME ANYONE WITH REGARD TO
THEIR SEXUALITY RACE ETHNIC OR
RELIGIOUS BACKGROUND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FOR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY AS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE SEVEN TWO. AND I THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR US AS A
STATE TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OUR ACTIONS.
TO NOT ONLY SAY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE OUR ONE MISTAKES.
BUT THE WE ARE SORRY FOR THEM
AND THAT WE WILL ENSURE THAT
THEY NEVER HAPPEN AGAIN.
APOLOGIES SHOULD NOT ONLY BE THE
END OF A TRAGIC CHAPTER OF OUR
HISTORY BUT ALSO THE BEGINNING
OF A BOLD AND INCLUSIVE FUTURE.
IN WHICH WE CAN SHOW THE WORLD
THAT WE ARE TRULY A NATION THAT
BELIEVES IN HUMAN RIGHTS FOR
ALL.
WE MUST BEGIN WITH OURSELVES AND
THIS HOUSE.
IT MUST INCLUDE MEANINGFUL
ACTION THAT WOULD LEAD THAT WILL
LEAD TWO EDUCATION AND LONG TERM
SYSTEMIC CHANGE.
THE TWO MOST IMPORTANT WAYS TO
DO THIS.
I TO ENSURE.
STRONG VISIBLE ENVIRON LGBTQ
COMMUNITIES
AND TO MAKE SURE LGBT Q.
STUDENTS SEE THEMSELVES IN THEIR
HISTORY BOOKS.
BECAUSE WITHOUT A COMPLETE
HISTORY THERE CAN BE NO PROMISE
OF AN INCLUSIVE FUTURE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
I JOIN ME IN SUPPORT AND VOTE
AYE ON ACR ONE SEVEN TWO.
THANK YOU SOME AVERAGE OUT.
AS HARD AS A MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY TWO. THIS IS A MUCH
NEEDED RESOLUTION ON THE
CALIFORNIA.
SHOULD HAVE DONE FAR LONG AGO.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
NATURE OF PREVIOUS LAWS THAT
WERE ENACTED AND ENFORCED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OUR LGBT
RESIDENTS.
ITS A MUCH NEEDED APOLOGY FOR
THE DETRIMENTAL IMPACT THAT
BIGOTED POLICIES HAVE HAD HONOR
LGBT COMMUNITY. AS A MEMBER OF
THIS LEGISLATURE AND AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHICH IS HOME TO THE LARGEST
PERCENTAGE OF ADULT LGBT. AND
CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE ARE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO ADDRESS THE
HISTORY OF OUR STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
THIS MORNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS.
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
SEVENTY TWO.
I CALIFORNIA IS WIDELY KNOWN AS
A PROGRESSIVE STATE. AS
INCLUSIVE STATE AS A BEACON OF
HOPE FOR THE UNDERSERVED IN
UNDER REPRESENTED.
UNFORTUNATELY AS MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED THIS MORNING THIS
IS NOT ALWAYS BEEN THE CASE.
AS WE KNOW AS RECENTLY AS TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. VOTED TO SUPPORT
BANNING SAME SEX MARRIAGE I IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE THIS RESOLUTION THIS
MORNING WILL NOT TAKE BACK THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING IN DIRT FOR
SO MANY YEARS BY THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
BODY THAT WE TAKE THIS ACTION
TODAY FOR APOLOGIZING FOR THE
PAST ACTIONS OF PREVIOUS
LEGISLATURE'S.
IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW IT IS FITTING THAT ON MONDAY
WE CELEBRATE IT THINGS ARE
CHAVEZ DAY.
MANY PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW THIS IS
OUR CHAVEZ WAS AN EARLY
SUPPORTER OF THE LGBT MOVEMENT.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTIES HE WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST PROMINENT CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADERS TO OPENLY SUPPORT
THE LGBT CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
AND HE WAS A FRIEND AND ALLY OF
SAN FRANCISCO SUPERVISOR HARVEY
MILK.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN HE NOT
ONLY SPOKE AT THE SECOND MARCH
ON WASHINGTON FOR LESBIAN AND
GAY RIGHTS BUT ALSO WALKED THE
ENTIRE MARCH.
ALTHOUGH WE STILL HAVE MUCH TO
DO IN CALIFORNIA AND I
APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES SUPPORT
FOR MANY OF THE TRAILBLAZING
LEGISLATION LEGISLATIVE PIECES
THAT WE HAVE PASSED IN RECENT
YEARS.
I BELIEVE IT TO SAY THAT CHAVEZ
WAS ALIVE TODAY HE'D BE PROUD OF
WHAT WE HAVE DONE TOGETHER.
WE ALSO BELIEVE BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS BUT LET RESOLUTION THIS
MORNING.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS I STAND
WITH THE APPROXIMATE ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION LGBT LATINO LATINA
AND LET NEXT ADULTS AND CAN
UNITED STATES.
AND THAT'S MY COLLEAGUES FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE.
PORTANTINO ON THIS VERY FLOOR
WHICH SOME OF US HER FULL
LAWSUIT LGBT COMMUNITY WERE
APPROVED.
THAT WE STAND UP TODAY AND SAY
WERE SORRY FOR THAT AND IT WILL
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARE THE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALLY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY AMOUNTS BIGGER QUESTION THE
AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SO OTHER
MEMBER MANY MEMBERS OF OUR
CAUCUS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WITH SOME AN
IMAGE I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM SO I JUST WANTED TO
GET A COMMITMENT FROM YOU THAT.
WHEN THE BILL GOES TO THE SENATE
THAT YOU'LL BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
DAHLE AS I MENTIONED TO YOU IN A
NUMBER OF FELLOW REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS MEMBERS I COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH INDIVIDUALS IN THE
SENATE AND ADDRESSING THE
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED
BEFORE US. A BUT I WILL NOT BE
TAKING MINUTES TODAY HERE ON THE
SOME WITH.
THANK YOU SEMI RETIREMENT YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS A PROUD MEMBER.
THE BLACK JEWISH AND LATINO
CAUCUS IS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE SEVENTY TWO.
I'M PROUD TO ADD MY VOICE.
TO A CONVERSATION ABOUT AN
APOLOGY THAT'S LONG OVERDUE.
FOR HER FULL LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN
ON OUR BOOKS.
THAT HURT CALIFORNIANS WHO
SIMPLY WANT TO LIVE
THE AMERICAN DREAM LIKE ALL OF
US IN LOVE WHO THEY CHOOSE TO
LOVE.
THIS CULTURE HAS LED TO AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE MANY OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE OFTEN BULLIED.
SPURIOUS MENTAL DEPRESSION
BECAUSE OF THE PRESSURE AND
HATRED AND BIGOTRY THAT THEY
EXPERIENCE.
AND IN MANY CASES PEOPLE HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO SAY.
THAT THE LAWS HAVE BEEN ON THE
BOOKS HAVE BEEN WRONG AND THAT
IT'S TIME FOR US TO WRITE A NEW
HISTORY MOVING FORWARD THING
ABOUT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE CREATE
ENVIRONMENTS IN THE LAWS THAT
PROTECT THEM AND SAY THAT LGBTQ
STUDENTS AND ADULTS HAVE GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES AHEAD OF THEM.
I URGE ALL MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE I%
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONCE EVERY TWO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ROBUST DIALOGUE DISCUSSION
MEMBERS.
AS A WE HAVE ALL SERVED IN
PUBLIC OFFICE AYE I'VE AS I SAID
BEFORE A THIS IS NOT ONLY TO ALL
OF CALIFORNIANS BUT A VERY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
I AS SOME OF YOU MAY ALSO KNOW I
SERVED AS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
MAYOR I FOUND IT QUITE STRANGE
THAT AS MAYOR. OF A CITY HERE IN
THIS STATE OF CALIFORNIA I CAN
OFFICIATE A WEDDING.
BUT I CAN GET MARRIED MYSELF.
I WAS ASKED TO HOST A BLOOD
DRIVE. ON CITY HALL PROPERTY
DURING A SUMMER BLOOD CHALLENGE.
ARROWS CONFLICTED.
BECAUSE I IS A GAY MAN COULD NOT
DONATE BLOOD BUT I COULD HOST A
BLOOD DRIVE ON PUBLIC PROPERTY.
I WELCOME THE BOY SCOUTS.
WHO WANT TO EARN THEIR MERIT
BADGE?
AND A LITTLE BOY.
ASKED
MISTER MAYOR.
WHERE YOU ALSO A BOY SCOUT IS
THAT HOW YOU BECAME MAYOR?
YOU I PAUSED AND SAW FRIGHTENING
LOOK OF PARENTS FACES.
THAT WHAT WOULD HE SAY.
I SAID ASK YOUR PARENTS.
I FOUND AND SAW INDIVIDUALS.
SACRIFICING OF THEMSELVES.
WANTING TO SERVE IN THE
MILITARY.
BUT MEMBERS A BELLS WE COMMITTED
TO COULD NOT BE PATRIOTIC AND
SERVE THEIR DUTY THIS IS SIMPLY
ABOUT. WANTING TO BE IN A
COMMITTED RELATIONSHIP IS SIMPLY
ABOUT SACRIFICING OF THEMSELVES
GIVING BLOOD TO SAVE SOMEONE'S
LIVES THIS IS ABOUT BEING
PATRIOTIC AND DEFENDING OUR
COUNTRY AGAINST FOREIGN ENEMIES.
THIS IS ABOUT DOING YOUR CIVIC
PUBLIC DUTY ABOUT GETTING SKILL
SETS AS A BOY SCOUT BECOMING A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY.
AND THIS IS ABOUT TALKING ABOUT
THEIR CURRENT FRAUDULENT
PRACTICE OF CONVERSION THERAPY
THAT BY DEFAULT THIS SAYS
THERE'S SOMETHING INHERENTLY
WRONG WITH YOU.
WHEN A FACT WE SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED.
IT'S CELEBRATE DIVERSITY
AND WE SHOULD LEAD
WITH LOVE.
THIS RESOLUTION DEMONSTRATES
THAT WE LEAVE AND LEAD BY
EXAMPLE.
BY DEMONSTRATING LOVE AND WITH
RESPECT AYE ELSEWHERE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THE MEMBER HAS ASKED
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
COAUTHORS MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ISRAEL IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS ROLE IS WORK CO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
THIS ROLES FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FORTY FIVE CO AUTHORS
ON THE MEASURE WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SIGNIFY BY
SAYING AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON YOU'RE
RIGHT COULD RECOGNIZE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING. BILL
TO COMMITTEE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
ONE STEINORTH FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO THE
PRIVACY CONCERN
PROTECTION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILDER ON YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
I'M EXCUSE ME MICROPHONE PLEASE.
WE OBJECT TO THAT REFERRAL AND
ASK FOR ROLL CALL PLEASE THANK
YOU WILL TAKE A ROLL CALL ON
THE.
ON THE MOTION.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO A DOESN'T
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISS WALDRON IS ASKING FOR
A NOBLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE FORTY TO AYE VOTES
TWENTY THREE NO VOTES THE MOTION
IS ADOPTED MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER TO
THE FOLLOWING THOSE TO
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY THREE
MEANT MEDINA FROM THE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE TO THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY BILLION I'M BY SOME
REMEMBER CHAO ACCOLADE AND
OPERATE TRANSFERS AND CLEARLY
IT'S HERE OF THAT PICKED
IMMEDIATELY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISH A NEW NON PROBATE
PROCEDURE FOR CONVEYING THE REAL
PROPERTY.
NAMELY THE REVOKE ALL TRANSFER
ON DEATH DEED OR OUR TD DE.
IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE EFFECTIVE
THE DEED MUST BE RECORDED WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF SIGNING.
HOWEVER IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER
THE LAW ALSO REQUIRES RECORDING
OF THE FAQ PAGE.
WHICH IS PART OF THE STATUTORY
FORM AND ALSO PRIMARILY
INSTRUCTIONAL AND REQUIRES NO
PERSONAL INFORMATION OR
SIGNATURES.
BECAUSE OF DOT AMBIGUITY THE
BENEFICIARIES OF SUCH DEEDS THAT
WERE RECORDED WITHOUT THE FAQ.
MAY FIND IT DIFFICULT OR EVEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO OBTAIN TITLE
INSURANCE AND MAY FACE A LEGAL
CHALLENGE TO THE ABILITY OF THE
DEED.
TO AVOID THOSE PROBLEMS AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY NINE WOULD
EXPRESSLY STATE THAT THE FAQ
PAGE IS NOT REQUIRED TO BE
RECORDED.
THE BILL WOULD APPLY NOT RULE
RETROACTIVELY ONLY IF THE TRANS
FOR OUR IS STILL ALIVE WHEN THE
BILL TAKES EFFECT.
NOT LIMITED RETROACTIVITY WOULD
GIVE THE BILL THE GREATEST
BENEFICIAL EFFECT WITHOUT
IMPAIRING ANYONE'S VISIT
PROPERTY RIGHTS.
AB SEVENTY THIRTY NINE IS BASED
ON A RECOMMENDATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION AND ALL OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN REMOVED SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
I'M SORRY MEMBERS PLEASE WHEN I
MEMBERS SPEAKING PLEASE GIVE
THEM YOUR UTMOST ATTENTION AND
KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
WITHOUT SEEING NO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE RAINN.
THIS ITEM REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL THE VOTES SIXTY THREE
ON THE URGENCY.
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO.
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FOUR A. B.
OUR SORRY A SIXTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE WILL BE CONTINUED ITEM
SIXTY
S. A. B. TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ SOME
LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER EGGMAN ACCOLADES
OF A MILITARY.
SEVEN NEVER EGGMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY IT'S A BILL SPONSORED BY
THE CAL BORN IN MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO ALLOW DIRECT
APPOINTMENTS FROM. THERE OF
MILITARY RESERVE TO FULL TIME
ACTIVE DUTY TO SERVE AS A
COUNSELOR. ARE CURRENTLY
POSITIONS ARE OPEN FOR MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS WITHOUT ANYBODY
APPLYING THIS ALLOWS EXPEDIA TO
GET KIDS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MOTION
PASSED THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY RULE
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE BY SOME
WOMEN WERE SANTIAGO ACCOLADE A
PERSONAL PROPERTY.
SEVEN NEVER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MEN'S BEGIN TO TO
THEIR PRESENT ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY THREE WHICH
WOULD AT THE COMMERCIAL BAND AND
PROPERTY LAWS BY INCREASE THE
THRESHOLD AMOUNT THAT IS NEEDED
TO TRIGGER AN OFFICIAL AUCTION
PROCESS.
THE MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THUS FAR
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM SIXTY NINE THROUGH SEVENTY
TWO.
PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX MISTER
QUICKLY THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX VICE
MEMORABLE OBERNOLTE INOCULATE
THE VEHICLES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU BETTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY EIGHT OH SIX.
WOULD ALLOW LARGE PITY CLAP
PLACARD IN VEHICLES EQUIPPED
WITH A RAMP OR A LEFT.
TO USE ELECTRIC VEHICLE PARKING
SPACES ONLY IF THEY'RE BEING
USED FOR THE PURPOSES OF LOADING
OR UNLOADING A PERSON IN A
WHEELCHAIR. THIS BILL WILL
PRESERVE PARKING OPTIONS FOR
THOSE LARGE AND HARD TO PARK
VEHICLES WILL AT THE SAME TIME
HELPING CITIES TO MEET THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ASSIST
BILL MOVES INTO THE SENATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MISTER FRAZIER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IS THE CHAIR OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY WE HEARD THIS BILL
LAST MONDAY. AND HEARD THE
COMMITMENT FROM MR OVER
OBERNOLTE.
TO.
TAKING WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
BUT I REMIND YOU THAT THIS BILL
WAS IN THE COMMITTEE ON MONDAY
AND HASN'T HAD A CHANCE TO BE
VETTED. BY THE STAKEHOLDERS I
WILL RESERVE THE RIGHT IF MISTER
OBERNOLTE DOES NOT.
WORK WITH THE STATE CLOSE OUT
PULL IT BACK INTO THE COMMITTEE
TO BE RE HER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
MISTER OBERNOLTE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON TWENTY EIGHT OH
SIX.
THANK YOU MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE.
I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR PASS AND
RETAIN ITEM SEVENTY FIVE AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FORTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE AND
OTHERS ARE NOT WILLING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
SEVEN MEMBERS DOWN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
UPDATING THE.
LAWS WITH RESPECT TO HOW IN A
CUSTODY HEARING HOW
DETERMINATIONS ARE MADE WHETHER
OR NOT A CHILD IS GOING TO BE
PLACED. WITH A PARENT WHO HAS
BAD OR HAS A HISTORY OF BEING A
BATTERER.
THE NOTION IS TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE KEEPING KIDS SAFE
AND AWAY FROM A POTENTIALLY
BATTERING SPOUSE IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE NOW I WILL FULLY
ADMIT THAT THIS IS A VERY.
DIFFICULT AREA OF THE LAW.
TO BE ABLE TO BE PASSING
STATUTES AND AND I HAVE HEARD
FROM A NUMBER OF YOU WHO HAVE
RAISED SOME CONCERNS WE'RE
CONTINUING TO HAVE STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS WE WILL AGAIN HAVE WE
HAVE ONE SCHEDULED IN MAY. TO
TALK TO THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
CONCERNS. THAT PARENTS IN A
CUSTODY HEARING OR GOING TO BE
USING THE LAW TO THEIR BENEFIT
AND REALLY NOT TO THE BENEFIT OF
THE CHILD. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
BENEFITING THE CHILD KEEPING
THEM SAFE. KEEPING THEM AWAY
FROM A POTENTIAL BATTERER BUT
WITH THE SENSITIVITY TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT REPRESENTS IN
THE NUANCES IN THE LAW SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU
THOSE OF YOU WHO. HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THIS AREA AND
WORKING WITH US ON IT WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS. AND HAVE MOVED A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OPPOSITION
TO SUPPORT OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO DO SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE. SEEN
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE BECAUSE THERE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTE HIGHS FIFTY ONE
NO ZERO.
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVE TO OUR NEXT I WILL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACCOLADE EVIDENCE.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TO FORTY THREE WHICH
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS FOR SEX
WORKERS WHO WANT TO REPORT A
VIOLENT FELONY PERPETRATED
AGAINST THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
DURING AN ACT OF PROSTITUTION.
OR WANT TO TESTIFY AS A WITNESS
TO SUCH CRIME.
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS PROMOTED
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF OUR STATE
BY ENCOURAGING ALL CALIFORNIANS
TO REPORT CRIMES. EVERY VICTIMS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR LINE OF WORK
DESERVES THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HEARD AND TO BE PROTECTED.
ONE SAN FRANCISCO BAY STUDY
FOUND THAT OVER SIXTY PERCENT OF
SEX WORKERS FACE SOME FORM OF
ASSAULT WHILE ENGAGING IN THEIR
SEX WORK.
BY ENCOURAGING THESE WORKERS TO
COME FORWARD AFTER BEING
ASSAULTED WE WILL BE HELPING LAW
ENFORCEMENT REMOVE VIOLENT
PREDATORS FROM OUR STREETS.
SEX WORKERS ARE OFTEN TARGETED
BY SEXUAL PREDATORS BECAUSE THEY
KNOW A SEX WORKER IS LESS
LIKELY.
TO RESULT THESE CRIMES BECAUSE
OF FEAR OF PROSECUTION.
BY PROHIBITING EVIDENCE OF
CRIMINAL LIABILITY IN SUCH CASES
WE ARE SUPPORTING ONE OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR STATE. AND REAFFIRMING THAT
THEY DESERVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS OF ALL AS ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT COMMITTEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
CLICK WILL OPEN THE WORLD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THEIR OWN
TALENT A VOTE. I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEVER IS A MOVEMENT TO. SENATE
THIRD READING FOR THE PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS.
ONE ITEM SEVENTY SIX S. B. SIX
OR SIX QUICKLY UNDER NEWS.
SENATE BILL SIX OF SIX MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
ON THE AMENDMENTS THIS FRIEDMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SB SIX
OH SIX WHICH ADDRESSES LONG TERM
WATER EFFICIENCY IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE AMENDMENTS REPRESENT
COMMITMENTS THE AUTHOR AND
MYSELF HAVE MADE TO MEMBERS OF
THIS HOUSE AND WATER AGENCIES
AFTER DOZENS OF HOURS OF
MEETINGS OVER THE FALL AND
WINTER.
IMPORTANTLY THEY CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE WORK BILL FORWARD
TOWARDS A MORE CLEAR AND DEFINED
PATH FOR LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO
IMPLEMENT LOCALLY APPROPRIATE
WATER EFFICIENCY.
WE CONTINUE TO MEET WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND ARE WORKING
TOWARD SETTING CALIFORNIA ON A
PATH TO MAKE WATER FISHING TO
YOUR WAY OF LIFE. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTES ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN MIS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ON SOME OF THE TIME
THIS FLOOR HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THE WATER. OF.
ISSUES AND HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST AND I HAVE IT SPENT
MUCH MUCH TIME TRYING TO COME TO
A RESOLUTION I'D KNOWLEDGE AND
THANK THE AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
FOR AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY. YET
THERE IS A LOT MORE WORK AHEAD
OF US AND BEFORE I TAKE A VOTE
ON THIS BILL I WOULD LIKE US TO
SIT DOWN AND CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. ALTHOUGH THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE MOVING US FORWARD
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I WOULD
LIKE TO RESERVE MY VOTE. AYE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS MOVING FORWARD
MY COLLEAGUES AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS OF
THESE WATER CONSERVATION BILLS
SO THAT WE ALL CAN COME TO A
CONSENSUS AND OUT OF. A SOLUTION
TO OUR WATER.
ISSUES THANK YOU THANK YOU THIS
REVIEW. MISTER GARCIA YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AS THE
CHAIR OF THE WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF EFFORT. IN TRYING TO COALESCE
AROUND THE CONCEPTS OF WATER
CONSERVATION.
CONSIDERING ALL OF THE DIVERSE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATIONS OF THE
STATE.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THAT
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT AND THE
COMMITMENT OF A HANDFUL OF OTHER
LEGISLATORS.
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THE
PUBLIC POLICY AT HAND AND HOPE
THAT WE BRING FORWARD A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF WATER
CONSERVATION.
BILLS.
BEFORE THE END OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION THAT MERE
ALL OF THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
HAVE TAKEN PLACE AND ADDRESS THE
ISSUES OF BOTH WATER AGENCIES.
DOMESTIC. CONSUMERS AS WELL IS
THAT.
MEETING THE PUBLIC POLICY.
THAT WILL GET US TO A PLACE
WHERE ULTIMATELY THAT WE ARE
BEING AS EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE.
WITH THAT A VERY PRECIOUS
RESOURCE WHICH IS OUR WATER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I I URGE UP MY COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER GARCIA.
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK WITH THREE MILLION LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THESE ARE AMENDMENTS WE ARE
CONTINUING THE PROCESS OF
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND I
AND I VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
WE ARE UNDERGOING.
THANK HIS FRIEDMAN THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
OKAY OF SUCH A SORRY NOT
OBJECTION.
WILL TAKE A VOICE SPOKE.
ALL OF THE PAPERS PLEASE SAY
AYE.
ALL THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
IN THE JUDGE OR THE CHAIR THE
AYES HAVE IT.
AND MINUTES ARE ADOPTED.
SO GO OUT TO PAY IN THE BACK
WILL GO BACK TO BROWN.
NUMBER SO ON THE THIRD READING
FILE FOR SENATE BILLS OF QUICK
PLEASE INTRODUCE ITEMS ANY SEVEN
SCR SEVENTY FOUR SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
FOUR BY CENTER WIENER OTHERS
RELATIVES HIV VIRAL SUPPRESSION.
MISS WALDRON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT S. C. R.
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR WIENER A
RESOLUTION AIMED THAT
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANT ROLE.
THAT VIRAL LOAD SUPPRESSION
PLAYS IN REDUCING HIV
TRANSMISSION AND IMPROVING
HEALTH OUTCOMES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE TODAY WITH HIV
AIDS AND ARE UNAWARE OF THEIR
STATUS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH'S OFFICE OF AIDS HAS
EXPRESSED ITS DESIRE. THAT ONE
DAY ALL PEOPLE LIVING WITH AIDS
HIV IN CALIFORNIA ARE VIRAL E.
SUPPRESS.
IN RECENT YEARS HAS PURSUED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND OTHER
AGENCIES. KNOWN AS THE AFFINITY
PROJECT AIMED AT PROMOTING AN
IMPROVING VIRAL LOAD SUPPRESSION
TREATMENTS.
TREATMENT WITH VIRAL LOAD
SUPPRESSION CAN SAVE STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAMS UP TO ONE
MILLION DOLLARS PER TREATED
PATIENT.
REDUCE THE RISK OF TRANSMISSION
MISSION BY NINETY SIX PERCENT OR
MORE THE MOST IMPORTANTLY SAVE
THE LIVES OF PATIENTS.
IF ADMINISTERED CORRECTLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
AS YOU KNOW THE MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE
.
PUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTE. I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH TO MOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEN HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE OH FIVE BY SOME INFORMATION
ON THE OTHER FOR AN ACT RELATING
PUNITIVE DAMAGES.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT COUNTY.
MEMBERS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY FOUR NOSES ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ASSUMING WILL TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN.
I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SO WE WILL
TWENTY ONE NINETY SEVEN AYE
SIXTY FOUR AT NO ZERO MICHAEL
TWENTY THREE FORTY NINE. I SIXTY
FOUR AT NO ZERO SOMETHING
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY
ONE I SIXTY FOUR NOSY RAN
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE EIGHTY FOUR I SIXTY FOUR AT
NO ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS.
FRIDAY APRIL SIXTH NO FLOOR
SESSION NO CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY APRIL NINTH FLOOR SESSION
AT ONE PM.
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THOUGH
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED MEMBERS
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE MEMBERS.
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS HIGHRISE TO GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF JIM HOUSTON.
CALIFORNIA LOST A REMARKABLY
ACCOMPLISHED KIND AND GENEROUS
MAN.
WHO A DISTINGUISH HIMSELF
PROFESSIONALLY AS A SUCCESSFUL
DEVELOPER BUILDER AND WIDE WIDE
RANGING ENTREPRENEUR?
PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY HE WAS
A VISIONARY PHILANTHROPIST WHOSE
LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE TO THE
ARTS IN THE NUMEROUS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS.
WAS PRO FAMILY IMPACTFUL IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY.
HAVING LONG MAINTAINED A SECOND
HOME IN PALM SPRINGS TO WHICH HE
IN HIS LATE WIFE JACKIE RETIRED
TO IN TWO THOUSAND ONE. JIMMY
JACQUI BECAME PILLARS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
JIM EPITOMIZE THE MEANING OF
GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT OVER THE
COURSE OF HIS LONG LIFE AND IS
LEADERSHIP WILL BE MESSED.
WHILE MANY SEEK RECOGNITION FOR
THEIR GOOD WORK JIM WANTED HIS
WORKS TO SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
MANY TIMES OUTSIDE THE SPOTLIGHT
OF MEDIA COVERAGE.
HIS HUMILITY WAS BOTH INSPIRING
AND ADMIRABLE AS LEGACY WILL NO
DOUBT REMAIN FOR DECADES TO
COME.
THAT LEGACY IS EMBODIED IN THE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES HE TOUCHED
THROUGH HIS GENTLE.
IT KIND SPIRIT. THANK YOU I ASK
THAT WE HONOR THIS REMARKABLE
MAN AND ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER BASS.
FONG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMBER.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF ROBERT BOB CUNNINGHAM
THE LAST KNOWN SURVIVING VETERAN
OR PRO HARPER FROM KERN COUNTY.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MARCH TWENTY
SECOND AT THE AGE OF NINETY
FIVE?
BOB WAS A PROMINENT MEMBER OF
THE KERN COUNTY COMMITTEE
SHARING HIS HUMOR AND POSITIVITY
WHEREVER HE WENT.
THROUGH HARD TIMES.
BOB WOULD OFTEN SAY THE WORLD IS
A BETTER PLACE WITH A SMILE ON
YOUR FACE.
NOW MANY WHO KNEW HIM SAID HE
WAS VERY HUMBLE BUT A SERVICE
CITY HE WAS SIMPLY DOING HIS
DUTY. OUR COMMUNITY RECOGNIZES
THE IMPORTANCE OF A SERVICE HE'S
BEEN AUDITED EVENTS HAVING HIM
SERVE AS THE GRAND MARSHAL AT
THE ANNUAL BIG TO CHRISTMAS
PARADE.
TODAY WE HONOR SERVICE AND
SACRIFICE OUR COUNTRY.
HIS LOVE FOR LIFE AND COUNTRY
HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT ON ME
PERSONALLY NAY GREATLY MISSIN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING AS
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FUNG.
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'D RISE TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY
OF STEVEN BOCHCO WHO CREATED
LANDMARK TV HIT SUCH AS HILL
STREET BLUES NYPD BLUE AND LA
LAW.
BUT WHO WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY THREE TO AN ARTISTIC NEW
YORK FAMILY AND INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH HIS PARENTS A VIOLINIST.
AND A PAINTER HAD NO INTEREST IN
TELEVISION AND BOCHCO A FUTURE
EMMY AWARD WINNER DIDN'T HAVE A
TV IN HIS HOME UNTIL FRIENDS AND
NEIGHBORS. PITCHED IN TO BUY ONE
FOR THEM.
BUT WHO ATTENDED THE MANHATTAN
HIGH SCHOOL OF MUSIC AND WENT ON
TO ATTEND AND WHY YOU.
AND THE CARNEGIE INSTITUTE OF
TECHNOLOGY WHERE YOU GRADUATED
THE DEGREE IN THEATRE.
HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
TELEVISION AS A WRITER IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND CO CREATED
ITS FIRST SERIES IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE.
WRITING THE PILOT FOR THE SERIES
COLUMBO THAT THEN HAD A TEN YEAR
RUN.
THAT PILOT WAS DIRECTED BY NONE
OTHER THAN STEVEN SPIELBERG AND
THERE BEGAN A LIFELONG
FRIENDSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO.
IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES BOSCO
BEGAN PRODUCING THE CRIME IN
LEGAL DRAMAS THAT TRANSFORM
NETWORK TELEVISION.
SHOWS LIKE HILL STREET BLUES AND
NYPD BLUE FEATURED LARGE
ENSEMBLE CASTS COMPLEX AND
FLAWED CHARACTERS.
RISQUE SCENES
SEE THAT WOULDN'T SEEM RISK AT
ALL BY TODAY'S STANDARDS AN
EXPLICIT LANGUAGE THIS WAS
UNHEARD OF AT THAT TIME.
BUT BUT SCHOOL WAS UNAFRAID TO
PUSH THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT WAS
CONSIDERED ALLOWABLE ON
TELEVISION.
OFTEN FIGHTING WITH EXECUTIVES
TO MAINTAIN CREATIVE CONTROL.
HIS VISION AND TENACITY PRODUCED
MORE REALISTIC AND AUTHENTIC
STORIES AND INSPIRED COUNTLESS
OTHER TV SHOWS TO THIS DAY.
OVER HIS CAREER BOCHCO WAS
NOMINATED FOR THIRTY EMMYS OF
WHICH HE WON TEN.
HIS WORK INCLUDED THE CREATION
OF THE SERIES COP ROCK AND DO
THE HAUSER AND MANY OTHER
NOTABLE PRODUCTIONS.
BUT SCHOOL PASSED AWAY LAST
SUNDAY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FOUR SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY
ITS PACIFIC PALISADES .
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE DANA
SISTER JOANNA. AND THREE
CHILDREN AN ASSET WE ADJOURN HIS
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM. MS NON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT I
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF PATRICK
AT AMEND THE VEGA OF OXNARD.
PATRICK VEGA ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
A MARINE.
HE DRESSED UP IN MILITARY
CLOTHES WHEN HE WAS THREE.
LEADER PROMISED HIS FRIENDS IN
HIGH SCHOOL THAT ONE DAY HE
WOULD JOIN THE SERVICE AND
FINALLY ENLISTED THIS.
OCTOBER.
AND WHILE HIS FATHER WAS ALSO A
MARINE HIS DRIVE TO SERVE WASN'T
JUST ABOUT HIS FATHER.
HIS DRIVE WAS HIS OWN GOAL.
BIGGER DIED SUNDAY OF A CARDIAC
ARRESTS LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
AFTER ARRIVING.
FOR BOOT CAMP AT THE MARINE
CORPS RECRUIT DEPOT IN SAN
DIEGO.
HE WAS ONLY TWENTY ONE.
HE LOVED THE OCEAN AND WATER.
HE SWAM THE BUTTERFLY STROKE ON
OXNARD HIGH'S SWIM TEAM AND WAS
WING. IN WATER POLO.
HE WAS A LIFEGUARD IN TAUGHT
YOUNG CHILDREN HOW TO SWIM.
AND WAS AN AVID BUT YOU BORDER
AND SURFER.
HE WAS A VERY DRIVEN THAT YOUNG
MAN.
AND WAS A GREAT FRIEND TO MANY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS PARENTS
AND SISTER AND A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT THEIR FAMILY. ALL WHO WILL
MISS HIM DEARLY.
INCLUDING OF FRIENDS AND
ASSEMBLY CHIEF OF STAFF GOT LIKE
IT'S THE END.
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY.
BEGIN IS THE MAN. MISTER FRAZIER
YOUR RECOGNIZE FEAR GERMAN
MEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I'M HERE DANGER IN MEMORY OF
RAYMOND NICOLAS ELDER.
ADLER
WHO WAS BORN IN MARCH TWENTY
NINTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX IN
EVANSVILLE INDIANA.
TO MARIE CLAIRE NORTHROP.
AND DOCTOR RAYMOND ADLER.
EFFECTUALLY REFERRED TO HIS
NECK.
RAYMOND ATTENDED RIGHTS MEMORIAL
HIGH SCHOOL AND WORK FOR HIS
GRANDFATHER'S GROCERY STORE IS A
CUSTOMER SERVICE CLERK.
TWO INFLUENTIAL MEN IN NICK'S
LIFE FOR HIS UNCLE WHILE
NORTHROP.
A FREE METHODIST MINISTER AND
HIS COUSIN.
PAUL WOLF SCHMITT A HOLY CROSS
BISHOP.
AFTER NICK GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL.
HE ENTERED SIX ST MINARD
SEMINARY BUT AFTER MUCH
REFLECTION.
HE CHOSE A DIFFERENT PATH.
EARNING A HISTORY HISTORY DEGREE
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
EVANSVILLE.
NICK WORKED AS A TEACHER A
SCHOOLTEACHER FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS.
BUT EVENTUALLY PURSUED A CAREER
IN THE MEDICAL FIELD.
BY ENROLLING AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF PORTLAND.
WHERE HE GRADUATED WITH THE
NURSING SCIENCE DEGREE?
DURING THIS PERIOD. HE MET THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE MARIE COOKIE
CARAVAN THOUGHT.
AND IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
NICKING COOKIE WERE MARRIED.
AS THEIR FAMILY GREW NICK WORKED
AS A.
VISITING NURSE FOR CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY AND THEN BEGAN A THIRTY
FIVE YEAR CAREER WORKING AS AN
OFFICE MANAGER. FOR CONCORD
DISPOSAL SERVICE.
DURING HIS TENURE.
NICK PROVIDE EXCEPTIONAL
CUSTOMER SERVICE AND VOLUNTEERED
WITH MANY COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS.
HE CONTINUED HIS PASSION AND
PURSUE FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
BY EARNING A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
NATIONAL SECURITY.
ENJOYED LISTENING TO MANY AUDIO
BOOKS.
UNTIL HIS AN UNEXPECTED PASSING
ON MARCH TWENTY FOURTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
NICK IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVING
WIFE COOKING.
DEVOTED CHILDREN PAUL ADLER.
LISA. ADLER DAVID ADLER WHO
NICOLE WHICH IS NICOLE AND
PARTLY BECAUSE OF.
WITH HER HUSBAND.
MARONE.
AND ANGELA WHICH.
THERE HAS BEEN GREAT.
NEXT REYES PASSION IN LIFE WAS
ENTERTAINING HIS BELOVED ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN NECKLACE
ALEXANDRA.
JOSEPH MARK.
MICHAEL SIENNA ANDREW
CHRISTOPHER ARIANNA.
LUKE AND CARLY.
HIS ALSO SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER
STEVEN ADLER. MICHAEL ADLER.
JOHN ADLER.
SISTERS MARINE TRIED MATTER. AND
YOU NEED JEANNIE EVANS.
WHEN HER HUSBAND ON.
ALONG WITH NUMEROUS NIECES AND
NEPHEWS IS GENEROUS LOVING
SPIRIT STRONG SENSE OF FAITH.
FUNNY SENSE OF HUMOR AND QUICK
WIT WILL BE MISSED BY ALL WHO
KNEW NEW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON HIS AND
DISTRICT NICK PRESIDED AND I ASK
THAT WE GERMAN MISTER ADLER'S
MEMORY. MEMBERS WE WERE NEVER
PROMISED TOMORROW.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL REQUESTS TO JOIN A MEMBER
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED AND RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
ESTHER BONTA MOVES AND. MS RUBIO
SECONDS OF THE HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY APRIL
NINTH AT EIGHT ONE PM.
WE'RE JOINED